anyway welcome to your playing glam
oreos that's ego or kovalenko if I'm not
mistaken the prentices sky is really
high rated in the high 2600 at least he
was in one point and we see that he has
a fairly high rating here I don't really
know all this that well let's see why
where he goes 26 is normal but it's not
the only move you can even play the
weird move 27 as I recently discovered
[Music]
not quite sure why you would go there
but well I may be out let's do this keep
it keep it simple okay Bishop f3 in
might have you five hmm that's true so
let's develop I'd still play if I know
if I we cannot do
hmm so Drago just see three here or I
mean that's kind of tempting to to chase
them let's try hmm interesting
[Music]
interesting what is he doing a night f5
coming or something like that that I
would take and of course your you kind
of want to do this Bishop a6 mate en the
bishop 1g 30 that I didn't see this
movie role oh not good I mean that it is
it's not probably not the end of the
world shall simply didn't see the idea
oh wow he's completely happy with this
ending check ok yeah my pawn structure
isn't all that great 96 I wonder if I
should bring this to the long diagonal
here Bishop age forms just chief fine
but maybe this is actually helpful to
provoke g5 or provoke this whatever and
the night coming come to to c6 that's
annoying this is why i played this so
quickly i have rocked my my bishop of a
square oh that's not good I was stupid I
was very very stupid
Jeff f1 that's bad and just as you have
2499 you play light as I playing idiotic
game yeah i came i think it's not much
to say yeah actually a pretty normal
position here i think nothing
particularly great so I mean I mean okay
this is probably not the best yeah if I
have to play this stuff like would be
three computer goes hook d3 here with a
good position hmm not exactly obvious
Bishop e3 I mean why this okay with
every move here probably and ta I have
to do this differently i just didn't I
just overlook this move and it is
annoying it really is so I have to play
this this before and then it's it's kind
of know it's kind of normal so this
happened and this is a this is an
inoculation check I mean I think with
good play I should be still okay but I
didn't play well now I was totally I
mean he said he was blitzing out every
move anyway not looking at the position
g5 FF already wins apiece I didn't see
this this at all that web bishop would
get into trouble only here and it was
clearly too late so here ya hear this is
not easy and the the bad porn structure
and he gets here it's not particularly
fun not particularly fun to play
opposite colored bishops would would be
a fairly easy draw but I don't get there
easily yeah I will look bishop a form
that that led them to this unpleasant
and then i blundered a piece that's what
it is thanks for watching